it is a statistical fact that Muslims do  not commit most acts of terrorism  domestically or globally it's  statistical you can't argue with it its  objective research data that Muslims do  not kill more than other faith groups  and that Muslims do not commit most  terrorist acts our mass shootings in the  United States however the way that a San  Bernardino is treated as opposed to a  Las Vegas puts us in a situation in  which we feel like at times we can't win  because we have to defend every lunatic  that takes one life or 16 lives whereas  other groups of people are given a pass  even when a person may be claiming their  faith or belong to their their group and  could murder 60 people without anyone  facing any repercussions for that and  our children have to bear the burden of  that if you think about how unjust that  is